we're in East Texas and it's been over a
week since Hurricane Harvey hit but this
area is still completely devastated on
the way here we just passed by a house
where a woman lost her father after he
was swept up in the water we passed by a
neighborhood that's been evacuated
within a mile because of multiple
explosions at a chemical plant hardly
any cars can get through on this flooded
Road right here we're half a mile down
the road in Baytown Texas which got hit
very hard by the flooding and many
families like this one are just
returning to their homes for the first
time so we're with Robert his daughter
Caylee her husband Leo and their house
was really hit hard by the flood the
water has now gone down you guys are
just coming back for the first time yeah
we came during the flood first probably
a couple days after rain stopped and it
was probably about four foot or five
foot above here and we went inside and
got rescued my pigging my cats and my
cats they don't leave you can see they
tore me up pretty good
you guys show us what it's like inside
right now right here this is the highest
it was I just pulled myself up to the
second floor I went up top came into
this house was floating about this high
no way yeah and we'll come dry it was
like this high it is right well that's
kind of this is the pillows drunk god
blessed me with a good job good health
so I'm very very lucky that we all got
out safe it's just it's upsetting
because I lost good sentimental stuff my
grandfather's Bible was down here and
stuff like that this is the house you
grew up in so the house is replaceable
so you guys have an amazing attitude
yeah I think I'm more chipper than him
but I get choked up think my grandfather
stuff my dad that is
young man other than that stuff I got
the irreplaceable stuff out but you know
there's some little things I forgot
about didn't have time about but yeah so
so you took what you could do in fact
came up fast it was good way back a week
on flood what did you take with you my
wife I'm from close myself I get have
cell phone for free call people you see
where it was already molding on the
cabinets
yeah waters probably I don't know paper
towels on about a no you're a little wet
so they got up you got above the sink so
we're here at the height of the flood we
with the water if I hardly around here
maybe well here's the here's a line here
yeah waist-deep ladies deeper here
that's what the door shut so your doors
act like a dam you know it's kind of
deeper deeper outside and is in here
yeah so you can see where that line is
there so I got the right there so it was
about the cabin occasion and and we can
go back back you up that way when my
office furniture was in there my gun
safe in there Hecky
the guns are safe in there no no they're
not in their safe took your guns and
helped them out see some light here but
it's just
how do you even begin to process like
next steps at the point right now I want
to think about where I'm gonna live for
the next they don't let me live them
forever
yeah just got married in July so first
July first they just sort of newlyweds
so dad get out the house here we live
out here in the country part of Bay
towns so people get for Mantle's I had
horses and they get cows so you can have
farm animals live I don't there's dead
cows floating across the street you know
there's horses were dead and rounded
it's really sad you know animals drown
people use them for love income their
house you know it looks cataclysmic yeah
[Music]
for us it's the little stuff that you
don't you think about like plates and
spoons so there's all underneath all
muddy water it's like of course that you
wash up but I don't have that right now
I don't have a pillow I don't have a
blanket but it's but we went from him I
wouldn't so if you take you take them
out of my life right there all my other
families and friends and people people
have they have nothing they got out what
they got out with
[Music]
you